Good morning body! Time for another day. Your
alarm goes off, you hit the snooze button
and lay there for few minutes between the
land of wake and sleep known as the hypnopompic
state. When you do finally get up, you’re
groggy and disoriented thanks to sleep inertia.
Most of it is shed in 10 minutes, but can
sometimes linger for a few hours. During this
time your body temperature is still low, but
your blood pressure is sharply rising. There’s
a 50% increase in the stress hormone cortisol
pumping through your bloodstream, in preparation
for the stresses of your day!
Time for a shower! It’s also the best time
to shave as clot forming platelets are most
abundant right now, making your blood more
sticky. Meaning less bleeding from cuts! But
it’s also the time of day when heart attacks
most often occur.
7:30am swings around and it is time for coffee
and breakfast. Enjoy the smell before sipping!
75% of how we enjoy flavour is not through
the tongue, but through smell! The vapours
pass through your mouth, around the soft palate,
into the nasal cavity and to the olfactory
bulb. Mmm that’s good!
Settling in at work, and your mental activity
is actually at a peak in late morning. Most
of us are sharpest 2 and a half to 4 hours
after waking. But your memory is impacted
as the day moves on. In the morning we forget
an average of 5 facts, but by afternoon we
forget around 14. Nooot if you’re a young
adult though. In fact the reverse is true,
with young people becoming more mentally alive
in the afternoon and evening. But, at night
our biological clock seems to turn off the
proteins involved in forming long term memories,
which is why it’s best not to cram for a
test all night.
It’s noon and it’s time for lunch! Your
stomach is able to expand as much as two and
half pints to receive a meal. Here it stays
for a few hours before it’s sent to your
small intestine. We digest meals without even
thinking about it - in fact, there is a brain
of sorts in your belly called the enteric
nervous system which performs everything from
sensing nutrients, measuring acids, and coordinating
the immune system to defend your gut.
Around 2:30pm and lunch has left us a wave
of fogginess and fatigue. After a meal your
body has a short boost in energy from the
glucose, but is then followed by a wave of
insulin, the hormone that transports sugar
to your cells. Scientists believe that insulin
might pull too much from your blood, causing
an energy nosedive. However, this phenomenon
occurs even if you don’t have lunch, which
has led to much research on the power of naps,
which increase productivity and safety.
4:30pm and it’s time to hit the gym. Though
many try to work out in the morning, studies
suggest that you may gain 20% more muscle
strength by working out in the afternoon.
Your airways are more open, your heart works
more efficiently and your reaction time is
at its peak. Much of this has to do with your
core body temperature peaking later in the
day. Even most sports records are achieved
between 3pm and 8pm.
Now you start off the evening by joining some
friends for drinks. During cocktail hour you're
actually more tolerant to the effects of alcohol.
In one study, those drinking vodka at 9am
had significnatly worse reaction time and
psychological functioning than those who had
the same dose at 6pm.
It’s around 8:30pm now and you catch someone’s
eye in the bar. Most of our mammalian ancestors
have ways of advertising their fertility.
It turns out that human women also give cues
when they’re ovulating. In fact, when looking
at pictures of women, studies show men find
women in the fertile phase to be more attractive.
You ask each other to dance - which brings
you close enough to get a wiff - after all,
your sebaceous and apocrine glands release
scents through the armpit which potential
partners may find attractive. And because
humans walk upright, the armpit is the ideal
body part to disperse scent.
It’s 11pm now, which is the most popular
time for sex(ual activity). Which has little
to do with our bodies and more to do with
societal schedules. In fact, levels of testosterone
are much lower in the evening and peak at
8AM. While semen quality is best in the afternoon
with 35 x106 more spermatozoa per ejaculation.
As such, couples hoping to conceive have better
chances with midday sex than during the midnight
hour.
As you go to sleep and finally begin to drift
off, melatonin is secreted by the pineal gland
which begins the sleep cycle, which happens
multiple times through the night. A change
from alpha wave drowsiness to lower frequency
theta brain waves signify early sleep. And
as your sleep deepens, your brain moves to
longer delta waves. For children, sleep is
the time in which 90% of bone growth occurs.
Finally, as you move into REM sleep, your
brain is as busy as it was during the day,
firing theta waves with burst of alpha and
beta. Though dreams occur in all stages of
sleep, it is during REM that our dreams are
most vivid and intense. Recent brain scans
have shown that neurotransmitters like serotonin,
histamine and noradrenaline are shut off at
this point, turning off reason and logical
sense of time - which explains some weird
dreams! We dream for an hour and half to two
hours each night, meaning you spend about
6 years vividly dreaming over your lifetime!
In the middle of the night, your body actually
wakes up periodically, in something called
microarousals. These can last only seconds,
but occur between 200-1000 times per night.
Though most of us in the western world sleep
all in one go, many past cultures sleep was
broken up into two periods with social activity
in between. Some studies have even shown that
we have two distinct 4 hour natural sleep
periods, which in the past would last between
8pm-12am, and then again from 2am-6am.
By 4:30am, your body temperature is at its
lowest and your sleep continues to move through
the cycle. In a few hours, it’ll be good
morning body! Time for another day :)